sondern schauen wir jetzt nach chemnitz
und vor allem oder frage wird es wieder
zu so heftigen krawallen kommen wie wir
es letztes wochenende erst in kassel
gesehen haben nein ist es nicht so sehen
nämlich die bilder des heutigen tages
aus ja auch gegendemonstranten hatten
eine versammlung geplant wegen dem hohen
inzidenz wert wurde die querdenker demo
dann aber verboten trotzdem man sieht's
jahres kamen hunderte menschen zusammen
und auch in zwickau versammelten sich
einige da sehen wir jetzt auch gleich
die bilder dazu
meine kolleginnen yasemin ja wo sie war
vor ort für uns und sie fast auch den
ganzen tag zusammen
aufgrund des zu hohen incidents wertes
von über 200 war die demonstration heute
von kritikern der ko ohne massnahmen
untersagt die polizei rechnete trotz des
verbots mit mehreren tausend leuten
gekommen sind nur wenige hundert die
versuchten einen demonstrationszug zu
starten der wurde allerdings von der
polizei sehr schnell unterbunden
es kam nur zu kleinen rangeleien und
auch zu einem flaschenwurf von einem
betrunkenen menschen aus der rechten
szene
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren